DECLARATION.
>> MY LORDS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, MOST SORROWFUL DUTY
TO ANNOUNCE TO YOU THE DEATH OF
MANY BELOVED MOTHER, THE QUEEN.
I KNOW HOW DEEPLY YOU, THE
ENTIRE NATION, AND I THINK I MAY
SAY THE WHOLE WORLD SYMPATHIZE
WITH ME IN THE IRREPARABLE LOSS
WE HAVE ALL SUFFERED.
IT IS THE GREATEST CONSOLATION
TO ME TO KNOW OF THE SYMPATHY
EXPRESSED BY SO MANY TO MY
SISTER AND BROTHERS AND THAT
SUCH OVERWHELMING AFFECTION AND
SUPPORT SHOULD BE EXTENDED TO
OUR WHOLE FAMILY IN OUR LOSS.
TO ALL OF US AS A FAMILY,
KINGDOM AND WIDER FAMILY OF
NATIONS OF WHICH IT IS A PART,
MY MOTHER GAVE AN EXAMPLE OF
LIFELONG LOVE AND OF SELFLESS
SERVICE.
MY MOTHER'S REIN WAS UNEQUALLED
IN ITS DURATION.
ITS DEDICATION AND ITS DEVOTION.
EVEN AS WE GRIEVE, WE GIVE
THANKS FOR THIS MOST FAITHFUL
LIFE.
I'M DEEPLY AWARE OF THIS GREAT
INHERITANCE AND OF THE DUTIES
AND HEAVY RESPONSIBILITIES OF
SOVEREIGNTY WHICH HAVE NOW
PASSED TO ME.
IN TAKING UP THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES, I SHALL STRIVE
TO FOLLOW THE INSPIRING EXAMPLE
I HAVE BEEN SET IN UPHOLDING
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT AND TO
SEEK THE PEACE, HARMONY AND
PROSPERITY OF THE PEOPLES OF
THESE ISLANDS AND OF THE REALMS
AND TERRITORIES THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
IN THIS PURPOSE, I KNOW THAT I
SHOULD BE UPHELD BY THE
AFFECTION AND LOYALTY OF THE
PEOPLES WHOSE SOVEREIGN I HAVE
BEEN CALLED UPON TO BE.
AND THAT IN THE DISCHARGE OF
THESE DUTIES, I WILL BE GUIDED
BY THE COUNCIL OF THEIR ELECTED
PARLIAMENTS.
IN ALL THIS, I AM PROFOUNDLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE CONSTANT
SUPPORT OF MY BELOVED WIFE.
I TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CONFIRM MY WILLINGNESS AND
INTENTION TO CONTINUE THE
TRADITION OF SURRENDERING THE
HEREDITARY REVENUES INCLUDING
THE CROWN OF STATE TO MY
GOVERNMENT FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL IN RETURN FOR THE SOVEREIGN
GRANT WHICH SUPPORTS MY OFFICIAL
DUTIES AS HEAD OF STATE AND HEAD
OF NATION.
AND IN CARRYING OUT THE HEAVY
TASK THAT HAS BEEN LAID UPON ME,
AND TO WHICH I NOW DEDICATE WHAT
REMAINS TO ME OF MY LIFE, I PRAY
FOR THE GUIDANCE AND HELP OF ALL
MIGHTY GOD.
>> I HAVE WITH HUMBLE DUTY TO
CRAVE YOUR MAJESTY'S PERMISSION
FOR THE PUBLICATION OF YOUR
GRACIOUS SPEECH.
>> APPROVED.
>> CONCERNING THE SECURITY OF
THE CHURCH OF SCOTLAND.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT I SHOULD AT MY
ACCESSION TO THE CROWN TAKE AND
SUBSCRIBE THE OATH RELATING TO
THE SECURITY OF THE CHURCH OF
SCOTLAND.
I AM READY TO DO SO AT THIS
FIRST OPPORTUNITY.
I, CHARLES III, BY THE GRACE OF
GOD OF THE UNITED KING DEMOCRAT
OF GREAT BRITAIN AND NORTHERN
IRELAND AND OTHER REALMS AND
TERRITORIES, KING, DEFENDER OF
THE FAITH, DO FAITHFULLY PROMISE
AND SWEAR THAT I SHALL MAINTAIN
AND PRESERVE THE SETTLEMENT OF
THE TRUE PROTESTANT RELIGION AS
ESTABLISHED BY THE LAWS MADE IN
SCOTLAND IN PROSECUTION OF THE
CLAIM OF RIGHT AND PARTICULARLY
BY AN ACT FOR SECURING THE
PROTESTANT RELIGION AND
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH GOVERNMENT
AND BY THE ACTS PASSED IN THE
PARLIAMENT OF BOTH KINGDOMS FOR
UNION OF THE TWO KINGDOMS,
TOGETHER WITH THE GOVERNMENT
WORSHIP, DISCIPLINE, RIGHTS AND
PRIVILEGES OF THE CHURCH OF
SCOTLAND.
SO HELP ME GOD.
>> I NOW INVITE YOUR MAJESTY TO
SUBSCRIBE BOTH COPIES OF THE
INSTRUMENT CONFIRMING THE OATH
HAS BEEN TAKEN
.
>> AND THERE IS THE KING
SIGNING, GENTLEMEN, THE
PROCLAMATION THAT MAKES HIM KING
NOW AS WE LISTEN TO THE ROYAL
BAND.
>> THE BAND IS HEADING UP
TOWARDS SAINT JAMES, WHICH IS
VERY CLOSE TO US, I BELIEVE, FOR
THE FORMAL PROCLAMATION TO THE
PUBLIC THAT WILL BE MADE BETHE
GARTER KING OF ARMS, ACCOMPANIED
BY THE EARL MARSHALL.
THAT'S A VERY DEEP CEREMONIAL
MOMENT, TALK ABOUT POMP AN